You started Aikido at a very young age, could you tell us about it?
A lot of the other teachers say that they started Aikido
because they were moved by O Sensei’s words
or because it was a Budo of harmony,
but for me, it was different.
Frankly, I didn’t want to lose in street fight.
I came here when I was in grade 7 at the age of 12.
I think it was June 1st, 1949.
What was the training routine like in the Iwama dojo?
Back then, there were no tatami in this dojo.
It was wooden flooring
so projections weren’t like today’s where you would be thrown on the floor
making ”bang, bang, bang, bang” sounds on the tatami as you took ukemi.
First of all, in O Sensei’s classes,
you would start gently from easy techniques and move on to more difficult ones,
so I started from suwariwaza and gradually moved to hanmi handachi, and then tachiwaza.
Guillaume started in the group of Andre Nocquet. Did Nocquet visit the Iwama dojo often when he was in Japan?
While I was here, I think that he came a few times, but not that often.
I trained with him a few times when I went to the Honbu Dojo with O Sensei.
When I was still in high school,
Mr Nocquet who was really well built,
but his nikyo didn’t work at all on  me,
while mine worked just fine, so he said that there was something wrong.
He was trying hard though.
Then Kisshomaru Sensei came to tell him he wasn’t doing it right and he demonstrated it on me.
That’s my memory with him.
When you started, the techniques were called “kajo” instead of "kyo", did they bear more resemblance with that of Daito-ryu Aiki-jujutsu?
That's definitely true.
When I was taught by the founder, we would use the kajo system
and call it ikkajo, nikajo, sankajo, and so on.
But when Andre Nocquet came to from France to the Honbu Dojo as an uchi deshi,
we didn’t have such a thing as a manual,
so Kisshomaru Sensei published the first Aikido book, and in it,
and in it, he didn't use ikkajo, nikajo, etc. but ikkyo, nikyo, sankyo, etc.
Actually, in koryu jujutsu, both of these systems coexist.
Kyo is written with the kanji “to teach”, but I didn’t know what it was at first,
I was wondering how it was supposed to be written,
and it's only when I read the book that I learned it.
So back then, kotegaeshi was the same,
but nikyo ura was called kote mawashi.
Now it's been changed.
Why were the names changed from "kajo" to "kyo"?
Well, I don’t know what Kisshomaru Sensei had in mind...
I think that it was probably because the kajo system was used in the Daito-ryu scrolls
that Takeda Sokaku Sensei used to award.
He probably wanted to move away or update things from that.
This is my just my guess though.
The 5 principles of Aikido are organized in a very similar way to that of Daito-ryu. Do you know why?
When I started back in 1949,
O Sensei's techniques where a bit different compared to those in his later years, even if they were both called ikkyo.
In Daito-ryu for example, what is called ikkajo is a set of several techniques, but that’s also true in aikido.
For example, we might simply call it ikkyo, but there’s a variety of techniques from shomen-uchi, yokomen-uchi, and katate-dori.
So there are different versions of ikkyo.
People used to say that there were more than 2000 techniques in the basic curriculum alone.
If the techniques called ikkyo to gokyo are also principles, does it imply that others such as kote gaeshi, hijikime osae, shiho nage, aren't?
Well, I think, whether or not it’s associated with the word kyo doesn’t determine the importance of a technique.
For example, the techniques from ikkyo to gokyo are all immobilization techniques,
and the techniques like kotegaeshi, shihonage, and iriminage are projections.
So the techniques under different names have different characteristics and you can’t simply categorize in terms in such a way:
"This technique is superficial and that one is essential"
It seems that the name "Aikido" was chosen by a committee wasn't it?
Well, I don’t know,
but it's been written in some books.
Apparently Hirai Sensei would go to Butokukai to teach on behalf of O Sensei,
because he was one of O Sensei’s students.
At the time, I’m not sure if it was called Daito-ryu Aiki-jujutsu,
but apparently it's at that time that they used the word Aikido for the first time.
I’m not sure about that.
When I came to join here, it was called Aikikai Foundation.
The Aikikai Foundation was approved by the Ministry of Education, Culture, Sports, Science and Technology in 1947.
Before that, it had been called Kobukai Foundation for a long time.
Then after the war, I think it was 1947, the Ministry approved the organization as Aikikai Foundation.
They were using the word Aiki back then.
And the title on my registration paper is "Daito-ryu Aiki-jujutsu registry".
This is what I signed.
At the top of the students' registry,
there are also the  names of people such as the Admiral Takeshita Isamu.
How was Ueshiba Sensei's art called before that?
Before it became Aikido, it used to be called "Aikibudo".
"Aikibudo"
As for us, when I started, we would always call it "Aiki" instead of "Aikibudo".
Not "Aikido".
I think it was before the war ended, probably before 1945, that it was called "Aikibudo".
You entered soon after O Sensei's move to Iwama, at a time when Aikido underwent a deep change...
Well, I think the end to the war brought some changes.
Different things… I didn’t really know because I was a child,
but when O Sensei came here, he wasn’t really well.
He was sick.
Until then, as you can see here, he had been wearing only a mustache,
but when he came here, he started growing his beard.
When I joined in 1949, his beard was already like this.
The shrine was built in 1943,
and before that, he would come here from time to time.
And then there was the end of war, as well as the Omoto incident.
O sensei was not affected though.
What was Kisshomaru Sensei's part in all those changes?
Well, for example,
I can’t really compare O Sensei with Kisshomaru Sensei,
but O Sensei wasn’t really interested in a setting up an organization.
I think that’s understandable because the Founder created a path where there had been none.
But when the foundation was created to a certain level, Kisshomaru Sensei started focusing on making it into an organization.
I think that if the Second Doshu, Kisshomaru Sensei, had acted the same way as the Fouder,
there would be no Aikido as we know it today.
The Aikikai organization.
So that way, I think Kisshomaru Sensei made a huge contribution to the Aikido community.
So when they published the first book,
they tried not to use words like kyo or kajo, that people who knew nothing about Aikido would not understand.
They used simple words that everyone would understand.
What is the place of the Ibaraki Dojo in today's Aikido?
That’s a difficult question, extremely difficult to answer.
Now, Doshu comes gives classes once a week,
and Waka-Sensei also comes to teach on Wednesdays.
Doshu is supposed to come every week to teach the Saturday class, but he is busy.
I think he still does once or twice a month though.
So the Hombu Dojo and this Dojo are on the verge of becoming one,
but our practices are a bit different, and some people get confused.
That said, it's been going well so far,
and if our instructors and the instructors at the Hombu can exchange more,
understand each other's practice, and talk frankly,
this would go in the good direction